[Music]
today's question comes from jenna in
baton rouge my parents have always
emphasized how important it is to have a
good credit score my husband and i are
debt free other than our mortgage when
we pay that off we will not have
anything left to show up on our credit
report
i have to admit i'm dragging my feet on
paying off our home because i'm afraid
of how it will impact us in the future
should we slow down our payoff in order
to keep that debt open as long as we can
oh boy should we keep debt around to
avoid i don't want to score pay money
so i have a credit score
there's there's real fear here
apparently
they're afraid of how it will impact
them in the future well here's the thing
i know about credit scores you only need
one
if you want to take on debt
and even then you don't need one for a
mortgage so their question is should we
slow down our mortgage payoff so let's
say let's go the hypothetical route they
pay off the mortgage and their credit
score disappears after a little while
now you don't have a credit score well
do you plan on going to get a car loan
and if you plan on going to get another
mortgage i don't know why you would but
you can do that manually underwritten no
no score alone with no credit scores you
did that yeah i did that and so there's
an arrest you went to churchill mortgage
with no credit score got a manually
unwritten loan
and you're not far from paying off your
house now no
uh we didn't we're about to do it over
two years hesitating in order to have a
credit score i have no fear of having no
credit score and we didn't have one when
we got the house obviously we have one
now and it'll disappear i don't know
what my credit score is i don't care
because i don't plan on going into debt
and so the irrational fear
is is coming in because they think how
am i going to live my financial life
without a score
well here's the here's the problem jenna
you actually believe
that you have prospered because of your
credit score because your parents taught
you that
and your parents were wrong
and that belief that you have prospered
because of your credit score is what's
holding you is what's messing you up
here because that belief is a lie you
you're believing a lie
okay no one is prospered
because of their credit score
the credit score is built on the fact
that you borrowed money
paid it back on time
and you grew your credit score why did
you do that so that you could borrow
money and pay it back on time so that
you grow your credit score why did you
do that so that you could borrow money
so that you could pay it back on
groundhog day and so yeah i mean this is
a dog chasing its freaking tail here
and you guys are just going in circles
and all you're doing is keeping the bank
open and not jenna open
and so jenna this is about what makes
you prosperous
and by the way your credit score is not
a measure of your prosperity it is not a
measure of your net worth it's not a
measure of your income as a matter of
fact it doesn't take any of those things
into consideration the only thing your
credit score takes into consideration
the algorithm that builds it is 100
based on how much you play kissy face
with debt
that's all it is
and so
you know the all of your fear all of
your hesitation is based on you
believing a lie and the lie is that
credit scores cause prosperity
and they do not they merely measure
how much you've been playing kissy face
with the bank
how much interaction you've had with
debt
they merely measure that and the only
thing they give you is the ability to
borrow again and more
which does not cause prosperity it
causes the opposite it causes prosperity
for the freaking bank
stop it pay off your stinking house
we did an episode uh on the fine print
all about this it's called the dirty
truth behind your credit score you can
check it out uh wherever you find your
podcast and we we did this dave we went
through and we talked to
uh someone at churchill and they
explained to us the manual underwritten
process we called apartments and found
out you can rent without a credit score
i've i just rented a car and i rented
hotels just this past week without a
credit score with a debit card and so
these things can be done but there's
this myth out there that i'm not going
to be able to move in my financial life
i can't breathe if i don't have that
good credit score to show everyone yeah
and it is mythology